déjà je sais pas uniquement que j'ai pas
voulu voter pour ma mère ingère il ya
quelque chose de bien plus large que
gens que j'ai exprimée dans mes idées
déjà pour remettre un peu les choses
dans leur contexte moi ça fait quand
même quelques temps que je parle de mes
idées et que voilà tous mes défis en
fait j'ai pas juste fait des défis
sportifs pour faire des défis sportifs y
avait une idée derrière il ya le désir
de laquelle tu les fais et puis une
volonté aussi de parler de sujets de
société qui m'importe moi et qu importe
ma génération et qui importent aussi
plein d'autres mondes et du coup
pourquoi est-ce que j'ai décidé de
m'exprimer à ce moment là puisque pour
moi c'est un moment qui est hyper
important en fait c'est un moment qu'ils
aient cessé c'est vraiment un groupe
clément bien sûr dans notre société on
je pense qu'on l'a tous vécu comme ça
cette élection c'était vraiment un
moment de bascule pour beaucoup beaucoup
de choses donc pour moi c'était
important de m'exprimer chiche et voilà
vous et vous avez tous vous allez tous
me poser la question mais pourquoi
est-ce que je m'exprime en public je
pourrais je pourrais le garder pour moi
arthur est ce que c'est en rapport avec
les embouteillages
et pas d'augmenter elle non mais donc
ouais là la question et toi moi je vois
les lits et voilà ce qu'ils cherchent
des poux dans la tête non non non mais
ils vont dire ils vont dire pourquoi tu
l'as fait publiquement oui mais la
question est légitime et c'est aussi
pour ça que je suis venu là pour
m'expliquer de ça en fait si vous voulez
moi de base mon argumentation c'est à
dire que je suis pas d'accord avec le
système je pense qu'il ya un vrai
problème systémique qui vient de plus
loin que juste les crises qu'on voit
aujourd'hui il ya la crise qu vide il ya
la guerre en ukraine on en parlait il ya
quelques instants la crise climatique
etc moi mon idée c'est qu'il ya un
problème systémique qui vient de plus
loin et que ça c'est simplement des
symptômes des choses que voilà qui
ressortent de ce problème de fond et
pour exprimer sa je suis aller poster un
tweet sur enfin tu ne peux pas leur dire
le taux de 6 mois si on réagit encore
quelqu'un merci je ne voterai pas
résidentiel les politiques sont réformés
je suis pour une transformation radicale
voilà et en profondeur de la société
kaka était en train de passer leur magot
on ne résoudra pas les problèmes de fond
mais tend un papier dans une union de
tous les cinq ans au premier tour ta
beauté
non j'ai aujourd'hui tour et c'est ça
qui a fait je pense
mais voilà donc en gros je vous y
encourage et voilà je voulais dire que
je suis pas d'accord avec le système et
pour faire ça je peux pas dire bah enfin
sont obligés de m'exprimer aussi sur sur
cette chose là et pour moi c'est
important de le faire parce que c'est
dans ce moment démocratique qu'on
s'exprime sur sur sur notre opinion et
suit et qu'on fait changer les choses ta
main et pourquoi j'ai dit que j'ai voté
pour jean luc mélenchon alors j'aurais
pu dire bah non je vous dis pas c'est à
ce match vote ouais mais je peux pas
vous dire à la fois que je peux je vote
pas au second tour et même temps que
j'ai voté au premier tour mais je vous
dis pas pour qui dans la journaliste m'a
posé la question pour moi c'était
important de mettre les choses au clair
et pas de faire la langue de bois et il
ya quelque chose d'aussi qui est
important de préciser derrière tout ça
c'est que nous en tant que famille
derrière on accepte que y ait des
désaccords en accepte ça on aille voir
10 notre avis et ça moi je trouve ça
vraiment et moi je trouve qu'elle est ce
que ta maman elle était au courant à
pense que tu as dis bien sûr non mais on
a discuté des champions avec maman je
peux te parler de minutes tu as dis
maman je vais pas voter pour toi est le
tanit est pas le seul mais
[Applaudissements]
mais on la donne et moi je dis une chose
comme il y en a parlé 1 franchement je
trouve qu anne hidalgo voilà je dis
franchement ces gens qu'elle fasse non
mais je trouve ça marche mais ici ça
chapeau parce que qu'ils en parlent
ensemble oui qu'est-ce qu'elle t'a
dialogue
mais si je lui dis ça tu crois que da
éminemment n'est pas dans son album
j'étais comme un truc moi je comprends
moi car il sort la ceinture comme ces
niches cap mon frère c'est pour ça que
je comprends pas aussi la haine qui a eu
après sur les réseaux c'est quand cette
personne ait dans mon salon et personne
n'est derrière pour comprendre ce qui s
bat ça c'est des choses qu'on règle en
famille en fait des siennes je dis c'est
que c'est là c'est cependant on a eu
tellement de discussions je pourrai pas
tout récent soit a dit que c'est comme
tu le sens oui on est on en est arrivé à
cette chose là d'ailleurs faut savoir
que quand on est le fils 2 quand on est
le fils de quelqu'un de connu on vit
derrière son identité yue et moi un jour
je suis arrivée je dis maman j'ai besoin
de deux voix d'avoir ma propre identité
et puis de de dire mes opinions et je
porte aussi des choses que beaucoup de
monde porte derrière moi et surtout des
gens de ma génération et c'est là où
j'ai eu besoin voilà de lui dire mais
maman j'ai besoin d'être libre de dire
ce que je veux on a discuté beaucoup
beaucoup ait eu des désaccords et au
final on est on est tombé sur cet accord
de principe de dire qu on fait chacun
notre carrière de notre côté moi une
chose aussi que je tiens à dire ce que
c'est beaucoup revenu sur les réseaux
c'est que j'ai tenu à chaque fois que je
faisais un défi à chaque fois que je
vois que j'entamais quelque chose dans
ma vie à me détacher de dell complète
yves qu'elle ne mette pas même c'est lui
demandez jamais me re tweeté méli mélo
sow n'avait pas voté pour elle pas
indiqué le
nom mais non mais c'est fou parce que
elle t'a dit tu prennes ans qui tu veux
mais il déménage et en même temps ils se
rattachent me disant ça ben ouais ouais
mais non beaucoup beaucoup plus en fait
on s'attacherait
mais c'est la vérité à 17 % dans les
sondages et jean luc mélenchon à 1% est
ce que vous auriez voté pour pour
revenir sur moi mon jeu par mangerai pas
voter j'aurais fait la même chose parce
que pour moi aurait voté pour jean luc
mélenchon sent en fait pourquoi j'ai
voté pour jean luc mélenchon parce que
je pense que ça sa manière de vouloir
une sixième république c'était une bonne
manière de faire en sorte que les gens
se posent des questions et pour moi se
poser des questions sur le système et
sur son fonctionnement
c'était le point de départ de la
création c'est à dire un truc moi mon
père je lui fais ça et c'est pour ça que
bravo hani hammoud mon père et mon élève
du livret de famille
on craignait
justement j'aurais juste avoir juste un
dernier truc parce que c'est vraiment la
grande question c'est donc quand ça
s'est fini que ta maman est ce que les
rapports sont bons oui les rapports sont
bons et d'ailleurs le week-end prochain
je l'emmène en forem d'évoquer avec moi
alors fais gaffe quand même faire de
forêt potter est totale et c'est tombé
non mais elle savait que tu étais là
soit oui elle sait que je suis le soir
on embrasse moi je l'embrassé voilà je
dis bravo franchement je dis bravo parce
que là ça bravo bah si c'est une
ouverture d'esprit incroyable non
non non
cheryl mondiale a raison alors
raisonnons et la raison est ce qui va me
dire c'est très bien il d'algos tous à
la raison pas peur je me fous de la
raison est aussi l'humain voilà l'humain
c'est que sa maman qu'on n'aime pas elle
sort d'une campagne extrêmement violente
c'est très affaiblissant c'est très dur
une campagne on prend des coups dans
tout ça rend campagne elle voterait
semaine prochaine elle est là elle a
fait 2 % le match
d'aujourd'hui je sais c'est de l'amour
de son fils de l'amour de cergy donner
la mort tout coup et je
n'ai aucun souci côté des raisons tout
ça aucun souci mais que tu mènes le dire
à l'antenne humilié thamer al en devenir
même même moi j'ai pas voté pour elle et
oui pardon tout ça pour le buzz c'est
vrai mais on fait la différence entre
les personnes et les idées après tout
dans votre salon la fête pas eu d'accord
mais moi je lis les salaires est situé
aussi un parler aussi du fond voilà moi
ce que je comme je voulais dit je pense
qu'il ya un problème systémique je pense
que notre société elle va droit dans un
mur et un jour là où on voit aujourd'hui
une multiplication des crises et la
seule solution pour moi est en tout cas
je pense que la seule solution qui peut
nous nous amener vers quelque chose qui
va tous nous rendre beaucoup plus
heureux que dans la société dans
laquelle on est c'est de vivre de
manière plus simple de vivre avec plus
de temps et c'est ça que je voulais dire
au fond parce que tout le monde m'a
repris sur cette chose là avec ma mère
mais le propos principal est ce qu'il
faut retenir de ce que je dis c'est
qu'on est tous capables de créer une
nouvelle société hanna tu savais qu'on
retiendra uniquement cette phrase là
qu'on retournerait pas le pommier la
raison foncez le damné cercueil
politique direct
de ta mère fois c'est faire c'était
s'était passé un appel en fait vous
laissez moi je voulais faire passer un
appel à tous les gens et je le fais
aujourd'hui je fais voit tous les gens
qui ne se reconnaissent pas dans cette
société qui en ont marre de 2,2 de la
merde c'est mon image je le redis
aujourd'hui on est capable de créer une
nouvelle société tout ce qu'il faut
c'est qu'on se regroupe alors fallait
dire
si tu pouvais me faire valoir de bus
vraiment je trouve que ce serait moi il
est d'accord avec moi
mais aussi à mon chéri tu as une heure
non mais ce que je suis d'accord avec
lui parce que j'aime bien ses idées
j'aime bien comment ils pensent et
j'aime bien sûr tout ça ni non et ça
remet pas en question le fait qu'il
s'avère il n'y a pas d' humiliation à
dire je ne me vante assez résidé ces des
idées et on devrait prendre de la graine
avec des jeunes comme aux autres parce
que ça c'est un jeune homme et nous on a
deux fois son âge on peut pas comprendre
on a deux fois son âge et le mépris beau
jeu voilà si bas qu'elle agit là et vous
faites les calculs donc lui j'aime bien
ces jeunes qui bougent comme ça qu'ils
disent les choses à son idée et c'est
vous vous auriez voulu qu'ils disent je
vais voter allez dago
[Musique]
hydro pourquoi ce qui lançait son idée
en ce qu'ils leur disent ce qu'ils lui
disent d'aller deux là
je sais pas qui sont ces des joueurs qui
sont ces gens voilà il me disait qu'il
fallait pas le dire ça n'est pas le cas
mais c'est un affront pour ça mais non
justement il est plein de sincérité il
est pas bien sûr
continuer à voir là dedans at elle fini
les vaches à bilad al shabab appartenait
alors castaldi ce même si c'est non
c'est non à ce que je sais pas j'ai pas
envie non mais en fait ceux qui n'ont
pas compris c'est ce qui ne voulait pas
comprendre encore une fois c'est lé
pervers c'est ce qui va le papa on était
vraiment mais vous vous mettez à la
place de quelqu'un que vous connaissez
même pas c'est ça non sans mal face d'un
suicide mais on a une mais rossi
anne hidalgo et énervé contre son
feeling non mes jugements justement moi
je pense que ta maman doit être très
très fier de toi parce que pour moi tu
es la jeune génération ol qui va nous
sauver et je pense qu'on est dans les
dents là dedans la nouvelle vague de
politique qui réfléchit à
l'environnement qui réfléchit
différemment elle seule envie d'alibi
toi qui es
fatigué qui commande tout ce que je dis
je les adore j'adore on en passe
mais laissez les épaules je ne riais
commentaires acérés le décor mentez pas
quand elles touchent rien dit ça a
commenté votre cul
bien ouais c'est ça je te félicite et je
pense vraiment que ta maman est très
fière de toi car tu regardes mais
laissez moi faire un kit je voulais
féliciter un arthur arthur
qui vous dit que son présentateur
préféré sartison l'afutt argent et bien
il dit à l'antenne
je vais vous dire reconnaît le talent
dont
voilà mais il ya quelque chose de
spécial pas de quelqu'un qui fait du
cinéma je dis aime pas les films de ma
mère on parle des sujets de société
c'est moi mes enfants mes petits enfants
ils vivront en 2100 30 c'est pour eux
aussi que j'essaie de match et que et
c'est pour eux aujourd'hui que j'ai
envie de parler benjamin castaldi vous à
moi je suis je trouve que c'est très
courageux d'abord il a un engagement qui
au public ouais voilà donc c'est bon
c'est ce qui fait c'est un peu comme sa
mère - dans ma famille quand j'ai fait
le loft meira des publivores que je fais
de la merde par exemple je n'ai pas
voulu voilà à l'adisq et ça c'est vrai
alors pour certains c'était vrai pour
d'autres pas du tout moi comme mon père
a fait fort boyard jouer j'ai dit
publiquement que je ne pouvais pas
excellent animateur que je préférais en
tant que comédien c'est pas une contente
de bataille ça qu'on perd
3,6 à mon père et mon portable
non mais moi quand j'ai commencé mon
métier et qui voyait a été mieux mais
même trouvé mauvais mais ça serait sympa
de votre famille mais c'est non mais oh
ça c'est un peu ça vous rend service
quand on vous dit les joues bien mais
dans mon esprit qu'il doit arrêter de
vous cacher des planches de bois d'été
dès que les choses tu peux te le dire en
famille par famille avait à l'époque on
a tous un
peu oui oui je vous apprécie énormément
mais là franchement je suis très en
colère mais il faut sympathiquement
contre vous pour tout d'abord parce que
vous êtes avait un fils qui je trouve
est discriminant méchant agressif sa
mère publiquement et ça ça me gêne mais
spécialement discriminant avant tvo tech
contre elle
la pensée les ans pas bien sûr je fais
des légendes et sa mère c'est d'avoir
accepté et est d'abord en avoir discuté
je trouve que c'est une preuve d'un
talent à nidal go incroyable très bon
bout et c'est bravo elle est la deuxième
chose mon cher arthur c'est que quand
même vous êtes jeunes vous êtes
privilégiez vous vous avez des parents
et c'est alors tu as tic qui ont très
bien réussi et vous nous donner des
leçons sur l'état du monde alors tombé à
l'eau moi je prenne mes bras
parce que tu vois pas ce que tu as des
parents que leurs ouailles système et tu
pense pas aux autres heureusement qu'il
est comme ça 11160
tu dis pas non quand on est bien né on
ferme sa gueule samedi passé j'espère
que quand tu es bien sûr jamais loin des
genoux à la maison tu dis bah moi je
m'en fous je suis bien en tout genre la
maladie lama né à bari ou décrit le
monde est un peu facile
arthur avoir lieu parce que moi mais je
comprends cette opinion gilles-marie
êtres
pleins de gens qui m'ont dit ça et là il
ya des gens qui se posent la question et
je cours je trouve ça légitime -
premièrement je trouve que c'est parce
que j'ai eu une vie même pas d'exil mais
je pense que sincèrement je peux le dire
j'ai été chanceux d'avoir eu la vie que
j'ai eu et je le dis publiquement mais
mois à partir de mai 15 ans j'ai
commencé à me poser des questions à me
demander ce que je suis vraiment heureux
dans cette société là et c est ce qu on
est vraiment heureux de tous dans cette
société là et c'est pas simplement le
fait que j'aie planque biens matériels
qui a fait je me suis un moment
magnifique détacher de cette de cet
aspect matériel de ma vie et j'ai
commencé à partir et c'est là où j'ai
commencé à faire des aventures à vouloir
un d'un mode de vie plus simple et
aujourd'hui j'ai j'ai vraiment détaché
de cette astra matériel de la société et
c'est pour ça aujourd'hui que je viens
et que je viens en parler à quai et
c'est ça n'a rien à voir avec le fait
que je suis un fils de cibler j'ai
toujours essayé de m'en détacher et je
sais qu'aujourd'hui suis pas dupe je
sais qu'aujourd'hui on m'invite parce
que je suis le fils de ben voilà
exactement combien d'argent
les choses à dire
chabat géraldine et après benhadj la
connerie qui a dit gilles j'avais
presque envie de changer
de maillot s'il vous plaît jamil et
yoplait
ouais c'est vrai juste scheer a dit oui
vous n'êtes pas parce qu'elle lanceur de
couteaux qui
s'occupe êtes vous oui alesi oui et non
en fait je te trouve absolument très
sympathique et bon quand tu es venu ici
tu as parlé justement ton action l'a
fait nager tout ça tu avais dit
d'ailleurs qui avait nagé qui avait été
fait des prélèvements est d'ailleurs
qu'elle était plutôt propre d'ailleurs
donc c'est intéressant ton côté
aventurier un peu utopiste
en fait le problème pour moi c'est que
quand tu fais ce tweet et quand tu as
août pour qui tu vas voter ou pas q ou
tu as fait tu est instrumentalisé c'est
à dire que tout d'un coup on écoute plus
j'ai regardé sur google aujourd'hui il
n'est que question de celui qui a pas
voté pour sa mère à 1,7 pour cent en
fait tout de suite on ne parle plus
tekoe mais justement parce que vous avez
louis lui l'entièreté doute du tweet oui
mais je tenais ce deuxième sortie de mon
tweet c'était justement je disais on met
les gens dans des cases et en fait tout
ce que vous faites et tout ce qui a été
fait après ce tweet là ça ne fait que
confirmer ce que je dis mais arthur
d'élu noir une phrase choc qui va
forcément s'arrêter là mais justement
c'était peau c'est aussi pour ça que
j'ai voulu mettre ça en avant dans mon
tweet pour dire aux gens mais ne vous
arrêtez pas à la casse dans laquelle est
médiatique je suis pour
je le suis là mais arthur vous n'êtes
pas naïf effectivement je peux tout à
fait entendre que vous ayez envie
d'évoquer un projet de société qui qui
ne vous correspond pas et donc que vous
voulez voir une sixième république et
voir autre chose et c mais en
l'occurrence comme vous connaissez le
système à la fois politique et
médiatique vous saviez que d'un côté
d'un point de vue politique vous seriez
récupérer et en même temps d'un point de
vue médiatique vous seriez tellement
récupéré et que vous seriez donc vidée
de la substance même de votre mère alors
on vidait la dass
je débarque là moi mais au final c'est
on peut avoir seulement importe ce que
je dis voilà moi j'ai eu à un moment oui
je suis fils de parme et oui j'ai le
droit aussi de m'exprimer a bien cherché
et j'ai le droit de ne pas faire la
langue de bois j'ai passé les 20
premières années de ma vie à calculer
chaque mot chaque fois que je prenais la
parole même avec des ânes ou même en
privé mais est ce qu'à un moment vous
vous êtes un album un millier ma mère
et est maintenant aujourd'hui ce ma mère
elle vient de finir son combat politique
et j'ai attendu la fin de son élection
parce que je son élection libre accès
mais
ces citations participation j'ai voulu
attendre la fin de cette semaine
d'autre part comme maire vous avez voté
pour elle mais mer
inventer pas à l'époque j'avais pas là
c'est l'avis de la principale intéressée
qui compte c'est à dire que s'il permet
l'adulte ça
voilà je disais que ce qui compte c'est
la vie de la principale intéressée si sa
mère qu'elle ne lui en veux pas je sais
que tout se passe bien entre eux qu'il
faut un bon relationnel où est le
problème en fait
elle rappelle le gargantua pas
ne lui en veut pas
oui il a raison il nous l'a dit il nous
l'a
tué s'il fonctionne comme ça c'est que
son éducation a été fait bien chaud et
ouvrir l'esprit
de faire ses propres opinions mais si
c'est ça sinon il se serait pas permis b
avait pas d'armes et des caches pas
parce que la majorité des gens pourront
pas de comprendre alors reste là dessus
et au petit à petit quand les gens
s'éveilleront il pour autant comprendre
parce que là j'aurais comprennent comme
la chine qui s'éveille ira
le combat que je mène il me dépasse
c'est ça aussi qu'on pas compris les
gens c'est que je porte quelque chose
mais moi je suis pas dans un besoin de
reconnaissance vous m'en fiche mathieu
tu as dit que j'étais là pour faire le
buzz mais moi j'ai pas besoin d'être mis
en avant à la foule voilà continent à
toi je pense arriver pas besoin de se
[ __ ] à moi c'est quoi ça
[Applaudissements]
la star de mykonos
quelque chose de plus large que ça et qu
il quelque chose qui me dépasse et c'est
pour ça que j'ai essayé aujourd'hui pour
faire un appel bravo jean qui a envie
d'autre chose à voter mélenchon mais
c'est déjà fait l'annoncé
autre chose c'est qu'il part sur
d'autres bases un autre système
démocratique
une vie plus simple qui est pas dans les
codes société actuelle où voilà on
aujourd'hui on travaille toute sa vie
pour essayer de gagner de l'argent pour
avoir la retraite à la fin de l'année à
83,2 m voilà donc la lll et celles qui
sont
isolées j'ai un problème de plus
j'appelle à la fin c'est un problème de
vue
[Applaudissements]
ou à 80% non et les gens puissent côté
douala
et aussi au père c'était quoi la
question c'est bon je l'avoué rollin
charge ok ça non les gens n'ont pas quoi
84 la photo c'est moi et le public noël
les gens ne s'est pas de leurs mots qui
va aller nager avec toi dans la seine
torkhani del bocco mais parce qu'on a
passé les chausser mes choix va hausser
meschonnic souliers lui demander s'ils
regrettaient haut
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]